c'est possible de limiter la hausse des
températures à 1.5 degrés celsius
la quête climatique elle ne fait que
s'accélérer
mais il faut faire des choix
canal va devoir faire des choix
difficiles
dans le contexte où on l'a vu cet été
tous ces phénomènes météorologiques
vraiment très alarmant extrême à quel
point cette coop 26 cette grande
conférence est importante la conférence
de glasgow c'est une conférence qui est
très très attendue parce que on est cinq
ans après la mise en oeuvre de l'accord
de paris il entre en vigueur et c'est
cette année où les états doivent revenir
à la table avec le rehaussement de leurs
ambitions donc présenter ce qu'ils ont
fait mais aussi ceux qu'ils s'engagent à
faire de plus pour qu'éventuellement on
atteigne les objectifs fixés par
l'accord de paris qu un tiers des petit
état insulaire ne pourront pas
participer ce sont les pays eux qui
vivent les pires conséquences du
changement climatique et qu'ils ne
seront pas présents pour adopter les
grandes décisions de la cop16 et donc si
la coop être un lieu équitable pour que
les nations s'entendent sur les
priorités climatique cette fois ci ce le
sera pas et donc ça va jouer quand même
un rôle important sur le contenu de
l'accord
selon vous quel est le grand enjeu la
grande question qui va nous tenir occupé
pendant deux semaines c'est de faire
tout ce qu'on peut pour garder
l'objectif de limitation de la
température à 1.5 degrés celsius à
portée de la main et donc de changer un
peu la façon dont on parle de grands
objectifs climatiques ce n'est plus la
cible de chaque état qui compte c'est le
1.5 comme cible principale qu'il faut
garder en tête et accélérer le pas le
plus possible pour que d'ici les dix
prochaines années on puisse être en voie
de limiter la hausse de la température à
1.5 degrés celsius
je pense que ce système le plus c'est
vraiment celui du rehaussement de
l'ambition des états parce que le
dernier rapport du giec est paru en août
dernier nous montre qu'on doit agir
maintenant qu'on doit arrêter de voir
des cibles simplement à long terme ou à
moyen terme mais que dès maintenant les
états doivent montrer tout ce qu'ils
peuvent mettre sur la table pour
réellement faire une différence ça va de
remettre en question le secteur des
énergies fossiles oui on va de notre foi
aux subventions aux carburants fossiles
ça va de voir comment on peut réagir
mais le secteur des transports pour que
soient en phase avec la lutte contre les
changements climatiques
justement est ce que c'est parce à
l'éléphant dans la pièce un peu en les
énergies fossiles tout à fait les
secteurs des énergies fossiles c'est le
grand enjeu qu'on doit qu'on doit
répondre maintenant si on veut espérer
atteindre nos objectifs pour 2030 et
2050 on doit freiner maintenant toute
nouvelle construction d'infrastructures
qui permettent la production au
transport des hydrocarbures donc dans le
contexte canadien ça voudrait dire
remettre en question un projet comme
chris martin ça veut dire ne plus
accepter de nouveaux projets de forage
donc c'est des choix qui sont très
difficiles mais qui doivent être faits
on
[Musique]
où
notre propre régulateur canadienne de
l'énergie projette en fait une expansion
de l'énergie fossile jusqu'en 2050 et
donc il ya une discordance entre les
approches et c'est ce qui fait en fait
que la contribution du canada à la cop16
ne demeurent pas tant crédible elle est
crédible peut-être sur pâques est le
vrai test qui est celui de la réduction
des gaz à effet de serre le canada
demeure encore derrière d'autres grands
états
[Musique]
et à cet objectif de réduction des gaz à
effet de serre d'augmenter si les
ambitions du pays où est ce que ça va
accrocher d'après vu ça va cracher à
plusieurs niveaux le premier c'est quand
on parle de rehausser le niveau
d'ambition ben ça veut aussi dire aussi
niveau d'ambition sur la question du
financement par exemple les pays
s'étaient engagés dans le cadre de
l'accord de paris avoir un plancher de
financement à la hauteur de 100
milliards de dollars par année à compter
de 2020 et en ce moment les chiffres
nous montrent qu'on n'est pas on n'est
pas encore là chaque état a son
interprétation sur ce que ça veut dire
d'accélérer l'action climatique et donc
on aura évidemment
les pays riches qui vont vouloir
demander aux économies émergentes d'en
faire davantage et de l'autre côté les
économies émergentes vont dire mais
qu'est ce que vous nous donnez en fait
pour qu'on puisse
vraiment croire que vous êtes sérieux
dans votre engagement les 100 milliards
c'est un engagement symbolique
ça fait 12 ans que les pays riches se
sont engagés à octroyer 100 milliards de
dollars pour l'atténuation et
l'adaptation aux changements climatiques
on sait aujourd'hui que les pays riches
ne pourront pas en fait mobiliser 100
milliards en 2020 et en 2021 et
peut-être même en 2022 donc la question
des 5 milliards c'est une question de
confiance et c'est au coeur même de ce
qui pourrait arriver à glasgow pourquoi
parce que sa confiance sans cette
volonté de coopération c'est très
difficile d'atteindre de grands
objectifs pour accroître l'ambition
entre états
qu'est ce qui ferait que la coop 26 et
un succès la cop16 est un succès si on
passe en fait deux
objectifs domestiques
vers une compréhension collectif de
limiter la hausse des températures à 1.5
degrés celsius et qu'on se donne ce
mandat mondiale faire en fait de cet
objectif là une question de justice
sociale d'équité des coopérations et de
renforcement des objectifs climatiques
on sait que le problème vient de nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre on
sait qu'on doit donc arrêter d'émettre
en 2018 le rapport du giec disait qu'on
avait augmenté la température mondiale
d'un degré on est en 2021 le giec nous
dit qu'on est à un point 1 et on voit
qu'en trois ans il ya une accélération
des bouleversements climatiques à
l'échelle de la planète on peut pas se
permettre de dépasser 1.5 donc c'est
maintenant que ça se sache où